thank you
hey everybody and welcome to an evolved
wild ride with steva we've got Moby and
man we weren't ready for him to talk
about his beef with Eminem in quite the
fashion that he did plus I had no idea
that I was going to fall in love with
them just so much man what a wonderful
humble guy and what a punk rock dude
what a thoughtful dude I mean this one
really was such a treat and hey man it
wasn't my idea for him to reignite his
beef with Eminem
yeah dude let's get into it
here in the back corner hey watch your
head yeah
oh nice yeah you're you're right here on
this mic
she's a chiller she'll probably bail at
some point
um so what is this place
seven
this is uh
this is our mobile Studio which we bring
to to our guests for convenience
and uh
can you angle that up would you like it
water uh sparkling water I might at some
point but for now I think I'm okay sure
okay we'll keep it by you in the cup
holder yeah thank you yeah
um where are you guys coming from
right down the road where uh Hollywood
Hills uh Lake Hollywood okay yeah that's
the first place I lived yeah you had
that crazy Mansion there yeah wow dude
like sometimes we go hiking around the
lake there's that trail and and it's
just like that's Moby's house and there
wasn't one house Madonna
she had there's like a giant weird
castle at the other end of the lake
and that was hers right
well then let's just dive into it great
ladies and gentlemen Moby hi Wendy yeah
dude and Wendy of course Wendy from Peru
um we've got we've got a little bit of a
history
well so from my recollection
and maybe I'm mistaken I think the first
time we met was one of the most
interesting neat cutes it was in St
Petersburg Russia
and I was on tour sorry Wendy
um and
I was getting ready to go to sleep
trying to be responsible touring
musician it was around 11 o'clock at
night which in St Petersburg in June
means the Sun was shining and all of a
sudden the phone rings and I pick up my
phone in the hotel room
and it's Johnny Knoxville saying hey
Moby it's Johnny Knoxville we've never
met but I'm here with all the jackass
and I think okay I'm not sure if we made
this clerk we're talking about Russia
yeah Russia yeah
right and and we were filming wild boys
the year was 2005. I don't think that I
was
um part of uh the program but wasn't it
like just a debater's drunken night it I
mean I got sober in 2008 and so
2005 every night was a drunken
debaucher's night but this in particular
like going out in St Petersburg and one
of the only things I remember from the
middle of my quasi-blackout was we ended
up at a nightclub and they were having a
dance competition
and you ran on stage and took off most
of your clothes and joined the dance
competition sounds about right I guess I
mean that checks out yeah you don't
remember this
the audience was so polite they just
sort of stood there like
baffled as to what was going on like
there's this sort of half-naked crazy
Drunk Monkey running around on stage
well it's Russia too yeah right what I
remember and I think it was the next day
that I had seen some Russian store
was selling a cast iron like complete
replica nine millimeter handgun that
when you pulled the trigger a flame came
out of the barrel it was just a lighter
but it was a cast iron nine millimeter
replica God I was fascinated by so I
bought it and I believe it was when
everybody was just terribly hung over
that
from from partying with Moby all night
the next day we go to the airport
and just when we go to go into the
airport I take the cast iron nine
millimeter replica and just put it in
the carry-on bag
I put it in the carry-on bag of our of
our line producer like our our uh our
super uptight like red tape conscious
you know like no fun police like you
can't do this you can't do that like not
not a creative guy but an uptight guy is
he is he still in Russia
I dropped it in there and like and and
at a certain point when he went through
security there were like
cops running from like every direction
of the airport like like this was
probably the meanest prank I've ever
pulled on somebody
but still I mean okay and the fact that
it's Russia like that would have been
bad in the United States and any other
country but like
yeah I mean it is on my long list of
crippling fears being thrown in a
Russian prison is up near the top right
for sure man especially these days but
but enough about that I um it's it's
crazy we get we both got sober in 2008.
yeah I think you beat me by about six
months I got October October 2008 right
yeah I'm March 10 2008. okay so six
months and the other thing that we have
in common is we're both sort of natives
of dairy and Connecticut oh how about
that yeah which per capita has the
greatest number of Oddball public
figures so daring Connecticut you know
the WASP is preppiest most affluent town
probably in the world
population I think fourteen thousand so
you lived there for a while I lived
there for a while Gus Van's antlers from
there Robert Downey Jr's from there Ann
Coulter the crazy right wing Fox News
person is from there Chloe 70
um on and on and on all these weird
dysfunctional public figures from this
little town of fifteen thousand people
and on top of that like I believe our
immediate Neighbors in Darien were
responsible for some like super high
profile prolific murder case oh where
because I I I want to say we lived on
Tulip Tree Lane yep okay I think you're
thinking of I his first name was Pat
and I can't remember his last name oh
this was when I was in high school and
it's such a gruesome story so there was
this adopted kid named Pat and he was
one like when you know when you go to
high school or Junior High School and
there's like the kids who just terrify
you granted I was scared of everything
but there were those kids who were extra
scary he was one of those like one of
the kids in the parking lot like
smoking cigarettes and like strangling
kittens
um and so one day he got in an argument
with his mom
I guess he was a junior or senior in
high school and he did what any person
does when you get in an argument with
your parent in high school he killed her
with an ax and then his dad came home
and he killed his dad with an ax
and because he wasn't the brightest guy
in the world he dragged their bodies
into the backyard set them on fire to
try and dispose of the evidence and got
into their car and left
his sister came home to find her parents
burning in the backyard she put them out
with a garden hose and called the police
and they found this guy a mile away
sleeping in his car oh my God he's tired
I think that was my neighbor
that was on Tulip Tree Lane yeah and
then you went to high school with him I
think he was like maybe a year older or
a year younger
but yeah we like one of those people you
just sort of knew yeah like on a
primordial instinctive level like just
stay away from don't make jokes around
this person because like
there were the the tough kids who would
punch you and push you into the locker
and then there's the other people like
this where you're afraid that they're
gonna like stab you to death in your
sleep yeah did you ever play with this
guy as a neighbor I don't know I'm not
even sure what the timeline is of the
murders compared to when we live there
maybe
how old were you when you were in
Connecticut I I moved there when I was
four and left there when I was six okay
so uh how old are you now I'm 57 57 I'm
48 so that that checks out I was in like
kindergarten and you were going into
High School yep yeah crazy man yeah wait
a minute what uh
what a eloquent telling of that story
the one thing I will say in telling the
story is you're allowed to be really dry
and boring in the beginning of the story
because it goes to such an unexpected
Place yeah you know you can be like oh
well he was kind of scary you know
scared me in high school by the way he
murdered his parents and set them on
fire in the backyard yeah I I love your
art man I I don't know if you if you saw
at one point
I just felt and compelled to tweet
totally unsolicited tweet that Moby is
my favorite Pandora station just type in
Moby click play and that that's
I just put that out in the universe wow
thank you I'm having a Maynard moment
where'd you go
but there are there are enough people
who hate me that that's actually kind of
an act of Bravery I can come out and say
that you like me I feel like there are a
lot of a lot of people who actively
dislike me so
man that that makes me sad to to hear
you say that I I think you're great man
and and I love
your I really love your music it is like
um my just
the best uh you know Just Energy it's
not like super like bummer it's not like
crazy it's just like well thanks groovy
now why would you say that a lot of
people just genuinely dislike you just
because of evidence
based on being alive
and and yeah I mean I work under the
assumption that some people don't
dislike me but uh yeah over the years
people have made it pretty clear that
you know some people really don't like
me very much
um
going way back you know a couple of
decades Eminem being the most famous
example of that
strap on your seat belts folks because
this Eminem talk is gonna get crazy and
I think we all know Eminem has command
over language but how many languages
right did Slim Shady know what this
means uh
La esta
gustando Me podcast which means are you
enjoying my podcast in Spanish and I
know that because of Babel the new
sponsor of the Wild Ride podcast and let
me tell you I tried Babel it it's uh an
app that helps you learn new languages
and man my experience with it my first
experience like wow it's like playing a
video game that teaches you how to speak
a new language in as little as three
weeks they had scientists studies that
said that using the Babel program for 15
hours is the equivalent of an entire
semester course in college to learn new
language and do you know that one in
five people have on their bucket list
learn a new language I mean dude I
decided to give it a shot I already
meditate every day I do yoga every day
why not spend five or ten minutes
playing a video game that teaches me a
new language and if you want to try it
man the listeners of the Wild Ride
podcast get 55 off their subscription if
you go to babble.com Devo that's spelled
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash Stevo rules and
restrictions apply but again listeners
the Wild Ride podcast
55 off your subscription for a very
limited time so jump on it and let's get
back to it that didn't help yeah I don't
know that I think that in the whole
Eminem thing I
I think that was an L for Eminem
honestly because if you think about the
world of like
hip hop kind of like gangster rap like
it's it's very like
tough
you know like to beef with Moby there's
no street cred in that even so the one
time he kind of published I have nothing
against Eminem I think he's really
talented I certainly
I almost don't have an opinion about him
but he attacked me at an MTV Music
Awards like 20 years ago
and the next day uh I was listening to
Howard Stern and Howard Stern said
exactly what you said it's like who
wants to pick on Moby you know it's like
picking on like the weak kid who doesn't
know how to tie his shoelaces like right
this is not but I think I think Eminem's
Mo at that point was just like okay I'm
gonna pick on anybody who's successful
you know what I mean just I don't know
about that yeah but the thing because it
was like Britney Spears NSYNC Backstreet
Boys people who couldn't fight back yeah
yeah yeah yeah but like hating on you is
like it's like you're not malicious in
anything that you do and it's like
somebody like like you're an artist and
so that's like somebody not liking
Picasso's artwork and just [__]
hating Picasso because they don't like
their artwork I mean like why would
somebody dislike you so much for no
reason I can't remember what the
specifics of the Eminem thing was but
but did he have any reason yeah I kind
of provoked him to me
sure so if you remember in the late 90s
there was this culture of weird misogyny
and homophobia like all of a sudden like
rock bands Etc were like writing songs
that were weirdly misogynistic and
homophobic and I having been raised by
Progressive hippies I was a little
surprised by this and I spoke out about
this because Eminem had songs about
killing gay people and killing women and
putting them in the trunk of his car and
I was like maybe this is not setting the
best example for the 13 year olds
listening to Eminem and then
um he got upset that I criticized him
and this is where maybe the whole I'm
gonna
throw myself under the bus a little bit
I thought this was really funny
but he clearly did not is I was doing an
MTV interview and the journalist asked
me like why does Eminem have such an
issue with you and I said I don't know
maybe he's closeted and he just wants to
make out with me
so that might have been my equivalent of
like pouring kerosene on the fire sure
so
so in his case maybe he has a very good
reason to not like me but I thought I
was just being funny but clearly I'm not
have you have you ever ran into him
since or nope nothing nothing he's also
in our Cult of sobriety yeah I wouldn't
be surprised
to to hear that there was uh an area I
wouldn't even be surprised if it
happened and just didn't come up because
we sort of leave that stuff on the other
side but I didn't think there could be
an amends there probably from both we
could do a mutual amendment is it like a
reach around amends
um it's it's really pretty rare I think
that like when you do come to somebody
to acknowledge that you were wrong I
think the majority of the time that
person meets you in the middle and
acknowledges their part too oh boy yeah
I mean that you know to shift from very
light-hearted and fun hopefully funny to
very Earnest like the ninth step which
is that the amends step oh my God it's
one of the most powerful things I've
ever done like reaching out to people
who I was convinced like they hated me
and I honestly made amends to them and
they started crying wow you know and
it's so
powerful and and transformation I don't
know if you ever if you had that
experience as well we are all in the
club all your own you're on the the
12-step cult yeah yeah we uh we're all
in the club we all are big Believers in
in the steps and um as transformational
as the ninth step is I think that it's
really
for me
um it was the inventory the fourth and
fifth step where where I realized wow
I'm actually
the creator of my situation that I'm in
yeah I remember because I had this very
old school sponsor
and
I when we sat down to do the fourth step
he was like okay just write down your
resentments yep and I was like you know
what I was a philosophy major in school
I'm sort of a Taoist like I don't have
any resentments and he said you know you
might just start writing 20 Pages later
I was still writing resentment so like
you're absolutely right and then when
the act of sharing fears sharing
resentments because up until that point
and I don't know what your guys
experience was I assumed that my fears
and resentments were things to be
ashamed of that no one else had and the
more time I spent with my sponsor and
going to meetings I realized oh
everybody has the same fears the same
shame this you know the same resentment
largely yeah I I had the same experience
as you I was kind of like you know
with the four step but it wasn't until I
was like man I really don't have
anything on paper and somebody was like
well you should write about yourself
and myself was the biggest resentment of
all and that was like
that was eye-opening for me because I
was like I thought I love myself and I'm
I'm sitting here writing like a maniac
of you know how resentful I am of myself
well someone sent me a a tweet a
screenshot of a tweet yesterday and by
the way I just feel like the most
middle-aged nerd in the world quoting
screenshots of tweets but the Tweet was
would you take fifty thousand dollars if
it meant giving a hundred thousand
dollars to the person you hate most in
the world and the person's response was
well why wouldn't I want to give myself
a hundred and fifty thousand dollars
that's great yeah man I love it when I
when I wrote my resentment list
and and took it to my sponsor
um it it turned out I really thought
that these people had wronged me and and
and then as as I told the stories of
each case that my sponsor said you know
like it sounds like they didn't really
do anything wrong and and that you owe
them in amends and and the totality of
the situation was that I had written
down a list of people who did nothing
but tried to help me and I had just [__]
all over them in the worst way and then
I tried to say I'm mad at them and and
it and it it turned out to be an
exercise of like holding up a mirror and
me seeing the reality of the situation
were you pissed at the guy that you put
the the smuggled the gun in Russia
how dare he not lock his carry-on
luggage it's just a joke yeah you know
and I I can think of somebody who is is
in that kind of same mind frame of
everything you and you and you it's mad
at everybody but actually everybody's
just done nothing but try to help and
and I think that the point I'm making is
that it was super transformational for
me in the fourth and fifth step to
finally see and accept my responsibility
and to get to taking accountability for
it and and I don't know if you guys did
this as well but I was told by my
sponsor that all I could do is keep the
focus on what I had done wrong sure you
know because like when I was making
amends to an ex-girlfriend like we had
had this terrible relationship like one
of those dysfunctional like drugs and
infidelity and just we were mean to each
other but couldn't I guess it's
codependent crystal meth still a lot all
sorts of things anything I mean at times
you know from GHB to PCP to whatever
cross-star transom and
I thought okay well she cheated on me so
therefore I'm justified in doing what I
did you know that I cheated on her and
my sponsor said no when you make a men's
tour you don't mention anything she's
done and it was such a hard process
because you wanted to say like well sure
I did this bad thing but you did this
right but by not saying that she broke
down in tears and it was this incredibly
powerful moment for both of us where we
admitted like oh we were both terrible
to each other like and it wasn't
reciprocal it was just that we're
unevolved feral monsters
what was your uh deciding factor on
getting sober like what was Rock Bottom
like for you you know it's weird I
didn't have a dramatic Rock Bottom uh I
mean okay
I did
but it was every day you know it was
basically every day I would wake up
around four or five in the afternoon and
my first thought every single time I
woke up was disappointment that I hadn't
died in my sleep
because the night before I would like
take
as many things as I could to try and die
while I was asleep you know so I'd have
like 20 or 25 drinks two or three
hundred dollars worth of cocaine
whatever drugs were given to me and then
at nine o'clock in the morning handfuls
of Vicodin and Xanax and I was like why
won't I die I just wake up you're just
like God damn it yeah and I would get in
the shower at 5 p.m just and just say
[__] like and I was saying [__] like I
felt sick I was so hungover but also
[__] why am I still alive so many people
would see that as being an example of
unmanageability for sure yeah but and
also just the hangovers and again I
don't know your guys experience but as I
got older the hangovers were so
bad like not just feeling sick but I
couldn't string sentences together I
couldn't think straight I couldn't like
you just felt like your brain and your
body had been possessed by all by just
weird chemicals and
so that that's why I had this thing
going on which I didn't actually you
know see as a reason to get sober like I
I would get such terrible heartburn and
and that it would wake me up I would be
in like so much like pain from the
heartburn that I it would wake me up I
would go into the bathroom and make
myself
vomit just all this like horrendous bile
and just acid and then I would be able
to go back to sleep
maybe that's why I have the the
esophageal condition but rather than see
that as a sign to get sober I went and
talked to uh
to uh our JP or jackass prop master
I was like man I guess it's heartburn
it's like
so bad and JP said I I had heartburn
really bad too and you know and then and
then I quit drinking and it totally went
away yeah and I looked at him said
what am I gonna do
yeah
yeah that sounds about right
dude I wasn't trying to be funny yeah
but yeah but like
anyway
um so dude we gotta talk about about
veganism
I've had a
by my journey I'm sure you've heard of
all about you know I'm vegan maybe maybe
you heard or didn't hear but have gone
back and forth between vegan and
pescetarian
um
I uh have been super frustrated over
I think what I would describe as
infighting in the animal rights
Community where like different kind of
tears of uh subsets of of animal rights
people feel that other animal rights
people aren't doing enough and then
bashing you know and it's like
at a certain point feels like banging
your head against the wall like hey
we're all
we're all rowing in the same direction
and rather than fight with each other
over who's not doing enough how about if
we just promote to everybody to just do
more and and identify what the real
problem is you know like it's safe to
say and I think this isn't just it's
true for veganism it's true for animal
rights it's true for Progressive
politics in general it's true for
environmentalism like people attacking
each other
rather than looking at the bigger
problem you know like every year one
trillion animals are killed by and for
humans isn't that a bigger issue than
like someone at a vegan restaurant
wearing leather shoes you know like or
someone who's been vegan for eight years
yelling at someone who's been vegan for
six years that they're still eating
honey or something you know it's like
focus on the real
issue but I
yeah I mean it's true for climate change
it's true for everything everyone just
is pointing fingers at each other and
meanwhile the actual problem doesn't get
addressed so yeah so
yeah I understand fully what you're
saying like for example I had an animal
rights fundraiser a couple years ago
and Reggie Watts came and performed as a
favor to me as a way of supporting it
Reggie's not a vegan and he was attacked
online for not being a vegan I was like
yeah but he's coming and supporting this
event he's performing for free he you
know he drove himself down there like he
having his name on the bill helped us
raise money how dare you attack him
when he's doing more to help this than
the people who are attacking him so like
I'm sorry that you're on the receiving
end of that sort of criticism I did I
guess it was a few years ago I spoke at
this event for uh there's this one
organization called direct action
everywhere and they are the hardcore you
know they're like they're that real and
I love what they do but they're very
militant and there tends to be a lot of
infighting and I stood on stage in front
of them and I said look I've been vegan
for 36 years which I have
and I said and I don't judge anyone here
and I guarantee you everyone in the
audience at some point was eating a Big
Mac while I was vegan and I don't judge
you so if I'm not judging you please
stop judging and criticizing each other
the Tipping Point for me where I really
I had a couple moments of extreme
frustration and one was
um
when uh
I told somebody asked me are you still
vegan and I said well like I've I've
reintroduced
Seafood into my diet they're like really
kind of struggling with that and I said
you know
um I I believe that it's healthy for me
to eat seafood and I have cats that like
really like I have to feed some kind of
meat to my cats and so I just figured
like okay
and and this person like went online and
I saw like a like an attack of me
for like not doing enough and and always
eating and and I actually snapped and I
posted uh this this picture of me uh
with all these veggies and it stuffed
into a fridge and I just wrote vegans
can be so annoying and uh and that was
my uh kerosene on the fire moment
um I think that and then all of a sudden
I have this like super like weird
feeling of like oh man not like uh all
the whole animal rights communities
turned against me and it's just it just
feels silly you know I want everyone to
just promote progress yeah and um the
other thing that really upset me
um whether this documentary that I was
actually in I had since I'd watched all
the vegan documentaries I was super
champion of them all you know uh meat
meat products cause cancer class not
frogs
I've been a part of everything campaign
all that you know um and uh the the all
the vegan documentaries saying that it's
it's animal byproducts that cause cancer
and so I I went to this um
I want to say it was a diet it was a
Diabetes Association fundraiser event
and I showed up at the diabetes thing
and they had a food laid out and among
the food laid out was a big platter of
chicken and I I stormed out I stormed
out and and protest I said serving
chicken at a diabetes event is like
serving alcohol at an AAA meeting which
they do in Russia
and uh and I was on this whole thing and
so then this documentary maker
approached me and said hey could we get
to you to tell that story about storming
out of the diabetes event you know for
this documentary it's kind of bolster
our scientific you know position that
that meat causes cancer and it's all
this bad stuff and I said of course and
so now I'm in this documentary the
documentary comes out and I watch it and
they're saying that you know eating
a hot dog is worse than smoking two
packs of cigarettes and like it it went
so
far into
frankly [__] that that I felt I felt
really
uh betrayed I felt used I felt that like
here I had bought on to all of this uh
you know
scientific you know the scientific
[__] where you know and I became so
angry at the idea that these
documentaries I mean clearly why not
just come out and say it that you guys
are want to be want more compassion for
animals don't twist science and make
documentaries that are telling people
lies just aren't true because
what about the people who became vegan
because they watched the documentary
then they found out everything that made
them become vegan that was said in the
documentary wasn't even true they were
lied to and then now it's like
and I just feel like I you know I became
the mouthpiece for this thing that was
just not it's just not you know they
twist up science sometimes to try to
help animals and it I think it's counter
productive
yeah twisting up facts is whack and you
know what doesn't twist up facts is my
whoop band baby this gives me more
truthful information about my physical
well-being than any other device on the
planet it's the most sophisticated
Fitness tracking device known to man I
swear by it the new whoop 4.0 is more
sophisticated than ever it tells me how
oxygenated my blood is my skin
temperature is in the right range I mean
dude it just goes on and on and on with
all of the stuff about your sleep and
your activities and your calories like
it's the best and if you haven't tried
it then it's time dude it's time to get
with the program by going to whoop.com
that's
w-h-o-oop.com and use the promo code
Stevo to get 10 off at checkout all my
buddies it we've got groups that we're
in and I'm killing it in the groups with
my heart rate variability which you'll
learn is a very important thing to know
about your own body that's why you need
to get on the whoop program so one more
time go to whoop.com use the promo code
Stevo for 10 off at checkout and then
show off to your buddies how how healthy
you are yeah dude let's get back to it
yeah I mean there's a lot of
distractions and having been involved in
you know the animal rights movement for
a long time and different other
Progressive movements
is like
it just I try to just sort of ignore the
crazies you know because if you go to
enough Progressive events or animal
rights event like there's bound to be
some unstable people there they're bound
and then they're bound to be the people
who are just so passionate that they'll
do anything they'll lie they'll cheat
they'll steal you're like okay
maybe that's not the best strategy but
you sort of have to I try to be not to
seem more enlightened than I am but just
try and be patient with people and and
their trajectory in their process you
know why did you become vegan 36 years
ago uh so I grew up like the way
everyone grew up with the weird Paradox
of loving rescue that we had a house
filled with rescued animals and I loved
them unconditionally like animals were
safe and animals were predictable and
animals were rational in a way like if
an animal got mad you sort of knew why
it was getting mad at you as opposed to
like a drunk family member who would get
mad because you showed up
um and so I loved animals but I loved
Burger King and I loved pepperoni pizza
and then when I was 19
I was petting this rescue cat named
Tucker and all of a sudden I had this
moment I was like oh Tucker has two eyes
and a central nervous system and such a
rich emotional life and by extrapolation
I then realized every animal has that
every animal has two eyes and central
nervous system wants to be alive and
wants to be happy so that was 1984 and I
went vegetarian then and then in 87 went
vegan and I've had periods of militant
veganism periods of not relaxed but like
periods of less militant veganism and
now it's just my ideas like how do you
do something on a daily basis in a
sustainable way you know and that means
not for me not getting too distracted by
like if I'm angry about this if I feel
resentful about this if I'm hurt by this
I just sort of have to say like okay
just keep going it's the one day at a
time approach to
I guess activism what's the problem with
honey you're not harming depends on the
depends on how well
a very extreme animal rights person
would say that every animal should live
their own life without human
interference I'm like yeah but the world
is a very complicated place that's the
militant vegan that's the Very extreme
the one problem with commercial honey
with is is that oftentimes the people
who are making like big giant commercial
honey factories it's cheaper to kill the
bees every year than keep them alive
over the winter so they will kill
millions of bees
because it costs less than keeping them
warm in a lot because during the winter
bees don't really make honey is there a
way to buy honey where you know the
difference between these bees were
killed and these weren't my assumption
is extra virgin honey like like small
batch local honey most likely that you
have to assume the beekeepers are nice
to their bees like no one is making like
my friend Chuck he's a brain surgeon but
he also makes honey and he has bees and
he loves his bees and he takes more care
of his bees than he does it himself for
his family so
you could look at this honey and say as
far as honey can be ethical this is some
pretty ethical honey like the bees are
I've seen the bees they're super happy
like you know they're very well looked
after they're kept warm in the winter
um
so I would assume that like the smaller
the batch of Honey the more ethically
produced it is but it will never be
ethically produced enough for
an incredibly militant person to S to
eat it does Manuka Honey come from bees
yeah why is it so it's like so healthy
for you because it's from I think it's
from New Zealand and I think that they
the bees who create manuka honey
are pollinating is it tea tree they're
they're pollinating something very
specific I don't know why it's called
Manuka maybe it's a region but like
every type of Honey like you have like
clover honey just means that the bees
have been pollinating Clover or
um orange blossom honey means they're
pollinating orange trees Etc
right well at least I mean or I could be
completely mistaken but that's and so
then then you have what oh vegetarians
were they they eat eggs because it's not
harming the chickens they're just
producing eggs and they're free range
not killing the chickens right and again
it's It's Tricky like my aunt and uncle
had chickens and these I mean I'm a
vegan I don't eat eggs I don't eat honey
but I don't also like my aunt and uncle
or my friend Chuck who has bees if he
eats the honey I can't really criticize
them because these bees are super happy
my aunt and uncle who have chickens they
live in Northwestern Connecticut
um these chickens are real happy like
they walk around they lay eggs on like
the roof of the car they are just very
happy chickens and if my aunt and uncle
are eating those eggs
I'm certainly not going to yell at them
and call them murderers you know so
I am
I remember the first thing that got me
started on my animal rights Journey was
working in the circus as a circus clown
and I felt that the the elephants and
particularly the tiger that their
situation was not something that that I
agreed with do you want to hear a funny
elephant story sure okay but I'm
interrupting I'm sorry
um
okay um and I love it dude I need to be
I need to be interrupted
actually you did tell me that
he's making it right after all these
times okay so here's a very quick
elephant story a friend of mine was
working for this organization called
compassion over killing
and they were protesting I think
Ringling Brothers for having elephants I
guess they don't know any right they but
this is back when Ringling Brothers had
elephants
and so my friend and her fellow animal
rights activists they chained themselves
to the entrance to whatever Arena you
know and it was like the bottom of this
big ramp and they chained themselves so
no one could get in and out of this big
ramp they locked you know like locked
themselves to this chain
and the people not this kind of funny
the people who had the circus brought
the elephants to the top of the ramp and
had the elephants pee down the ramp so
my friends were like lying on the the
ramp
drenched in elephant bee and apparently
you've had maybe I've never been around
I've been peed on by elephants
apparently it's not that Pleasant not
that bad yeah so she said
I mean granted elephants are vegan so
generally speaking Yeah the pee and put
I mean like for example cat pee and poop
as we all know it's disgusting nothing
against cats but like their pee and poop
is repulsive
but like elephants like they I would
imagine like they eat hay and leaves
like their pee and poop's probably
relatively benign right so sorry for
interrupting but that's my elephant
story I loved it like I said I need it
um and now to be clear elephants and
their natural habitat will walk about a
hundred miles a day is that right and
um very very social creatures and then
like with the Ringling Circus they're
stuffed into these compartments on the
train because the Ringling circuits
would travel by train the compartments
that they're stuffed into are like about
the size of their body you know for all
of the traveling and then they're
Chained and they can't walk like an
authors Chained and and then when they
aren't performing but what really
bothered me in the circus that I worked
in was that the the elephant Handler had
this stick and at the end of the stick
was tassels but to be very clear the
tassels served no purpose but to
disguise
like what was called a bull hook and
they would like you know like you would
use the hook to and like under the the
like the armpit of the elephant it was
like a sensitive area and they would you
know it just rubbed me the wrong way and
the circus owners seemed to be more
afraid of their own elephants than
anybody else like they're like first day
I was there stay the hell I'll wait for
the elephant don't go anywhere near him
you know and like I think that the
elephants had even charged and like done
some and then the tiger lived his whole
life in one of two boxes the the the the
the
um magic box where they had the Tiger
they would wheel out this box and it
appeared to be empty then they would put
a cloth over the box and spin it around
and then rip off the cloth and now all
of a sudden there's a whole tiger
filling up the box when in fact what it
was was just like a mirror like on an
angle that the tiger was like stuffed
underneath and then
when the Act was finished then they
would wield the magic box back and then
put it transfer it from that box into
the cage it lived in the little box cage
and I remember one time like hectic
transfers were like the Tigers freaking
out like it just lived in these two
boxes it never got to walk anywhere and
that that really upset me so I I found
myself at Tom Green's house
um at you know after jackass came out
and and like I I had a platform and and
I was drunk I was like inhaling that and
I just went on this tirade about how the
animals in the circus like it's so wrong
and and shortly thereafter when that you
know hit the internet like some a woman
who I love so dearly who at the time
worked for PETA a woman named Michelle
Cho and I'd be surprised if you don't
know Michelle yeah she lives around the
corner she reached out to me and she
said could I get you to tell that story
about working in the circus for PETA and
I remember I had some like some answer
like oh well you know like
get attention like I'm an attention or
hell yeah I'll just be like uh so I
could so Michelle brings a little Peta
camera crew over to the over to my
apartment and you know I'd tell my
circus tirade thing and then after we
wrapped up filming I said to Michelle I
said hey you know it occurs to me that
maybe it's a little bit hypocritical
that I just spoke on behalf of PETA on
my sofa in my apartment which is a
leather sofa but I want you to know like
I uh like because I eat beef I think it
makes sense to you know to use leather
you know in the kind of Native American
tradition of using the whole animal you
know but but with that said I told her I
said but I don't eat mink so I would
never wear a fur coat you know like
that's where I draw the line and that's
like that was my rationale at that time
she probably smiled politely you know
what she said was wow that's great could
I get you to wear or can I get you to do
a uh
wear ink not fur something an anti-fur
camera I was like hell yeah so then the
next thing I did is was uh I'd rather go
naked than we're first I've seen it
campaign and
um so that so it was just like that was
my journey it started just piece by
piece like what I could digest and then
no pun intended yeah for sure and and
then
um I had like my drug and alcohol the
situation got drastically worse and I
was
like hearing voices like watching people
walk around who were never there it was
really like heavy psychosis is that I'm
I don't want to distract from the story
but was that a result of specific drugs
because I always found PCP oh dude I had
great ones on PCP like I I remember one
time in Denver
lying in a hotel room and there were
like 10 people standing around my bed
and I was like I I don't know if they're
real or not and I would close my eyes
like 10 minutes later open my eyes like
those same people are standing around my
bed and like oh yeah this is this is
angel dust let me tell you about dances
going on around the bed and I'm talking
about my lady Lux dancing around my bed
when she finds out that I've just had a
Bluetooth tablet that's right Bluetooth
tablets with the same active ingredient
as both Viagra and Cialis which make
time in bed with my lady just way more
fun explosive if I do say so myself and
man if you haven't tried this then let
me recommend it to you because it makes
getting in bed with your lady a lot more
fun and if you want to get an entire
month's supply of Bluetooth tablets
completely for free then I got good news
for you because that's what you're going
to get if you go to
bluetooth.com and use the promo code
Stevo you go to bluetooth.com
promo code Stevo consult with the
medical provider right there online
within a couple minutes you've got your
prescription you got an entire month's
supply of Bluetooth tablets headed your
way for free all you have to pay is five
bucks for shipping man this is arguably
the best deal that we've ever had on the
Wild Ride podcast and if you still have
not tried Bluetooth tablets then I think
it is time so one more time go to
bluetooth.com use the promo code Stevo
to get your month's supply of Bluetooth
tablets completely for free all you pay
is five bucks for shipping now let's get
back to it this you know same people
showed up every time that in that one
night yeah like they just it was just
this group of 10 people standing around
the bed like so it wasn't like a
shifting hallucination where it was like
oh it's my grandmother now she's a
donkey it was like oh it's just some
random guy and no nine other people
standing around my bed did you try
having conversations with these people
you thought I was a little scared of
them so I was like and I was also like
you know I don't I don't know if they're
real so maybe if I ignore them they'll
go away yeah they didn't because yeah
like drops sorry no go for it do you
think that like drops the veil of like a
dimension so they actually exist in
another dimension or is it just some
chemical going off of in your head I
personally have no idea I'm in the
universe is such a complicated place so
it's like it could be
some other dimension it could be we
could be Holograms who I don't know the
truth of anything
um I do know that when I woke up in the
morning they were not there and there
was no evidence that these 10 people had
been in my hotel room yeah so in our
limited reality they didn't seem to have
much of a presence what about ketamine
for hallucinations ketamine is
pharmaceutical PCP yeah I I only ever
did ketamine in conjunction with 20
other things usually at five o'clock in
the morning and so like I don't even
know what kind of I've heard ketamine is
a phenomenal antidepressant like it's a
last stage antidepressant for people
with real clinical depression I've also
heard that if you inject it the exact
amount for your body weight it's the
most profound psychedelic drug on the
planet this guy Alexander shulkin who
was a chemist wrote about it but mainly
it's a rave drug you know people would
do it and they'd go into these catatonic
k-holes
um
that awesome
my favorite place to be so um but okay
so we're getting back to Michelle Cho
and not not eating mink Burgers right
yeah the what made me have the most
profound hallucin hallucinations tactile
You Know audio hearing voices and you
know seeing people what was um
days into cocaine
Benders binging on cocaine for multiple
days while enhancing
nitrous oxide oh nice combo to the
exclusion of air as much as possible and
I would hold in the nitrous nitrous is
still one of the greatest drugs like and
the fact like it's also okay now maybe I
shouldn't even say this but I'm gonna in
the interest of full disclosure and like
we're only sick as our secrets there
have been a couple times in sobriety
when I've gone to have root canals done
and had nitrous
and it boy it's still great like I
didn't want to do more when it was done
I didn't like rush out to try and buy
more nitrous but I gotta say even in
sobriety a little nitrous high do I need
to start counting days again that's
that's what you call a free laugh my
sponsor said that he was like he was
like did you take it as prescribed I was
like oh absolutely he's like and when it
was done did you run out to buy more
yeah no it didn't even cross my mind
he's like then enjoy it like you had you
had a free lapse yeah even though your
dental work done without anything I've
never had nitrous from the dentist that
I'm aware of ever but you should with
the like the workout
in my mouth yeah
um I I have looked forward to general
anesthesia in ways that creeped me out
that I felt that I needed to speak up
about with my home group
um but uh but in any case I had wild
hallucinations all kinds of stuff and
and I was so fascinated by the these
this phenomena that that it was so real
and I do believe that that um that these
substances somehow eroded the barriers
between dimensions and and and sadly
opened me up to
very low frequency kind of stuff I mean
there's different ways to kind of open
yourself up to higher frequency drugs
pretty low frequency so I had a lot of
demon activity going on and I that I
hallucinated like full interventions
where 10 people showed up to tell me
that they were worried about me and they
were never there
um and you were having conversations
with these people I was having all kinds
of conversations yeah with people and
and voices and and all that and so I I
just felt that I was privy to like other
dimensional entity activity and so
fascinated by it that I I just took to
the internet and searched like Spirits
spiritual you know like I just wanted to
to
get some kind of an understanding of
what I was privy to and in my search I
came across this video of
um a Krishna Consciousness Guru from
India was an Indian guy and he just
simply said the words
how can you expect to be saved if you
eat meat
it was just like you could tell I could
tell watching this guy say that that the
idea of eating meat and expecting to
find Salvation
it was just so Preposterous to him he
was just so confused by it like we're
here in this human jam and and I think
that most like religions agree that the
idea is to be saved or to ascend you
know some kind of like and and but how
can you expect if you eat me Airmen and
just like that flip the switch you flip
the switch I thought oh my God like I'm
I'm not gonna be saved because I'm
eating me I gotta stop
and and in that moment I also thought
but Jesus was a fisherman so fish is
cool
and uh now I where I stand today I don't
believe Jesus had anything to do with
fishing or eating fish but I see the
biggest problem I believe is factory
farming I think there's no question we
can agree with that yeah factory farming
and I think that as it relates to like
salmon farming fish farming like if
there's any like less bad version of
factory farming I would
believe that it is fish farming yeah I
don't actually know enough about like
aquaculture I mean but we can definitely
agree like yes and even non-vegans
non-emerites people will agree that
factory farming is horrifying absolutely
awful and so I almost feel like going
back to the earlier point and for
stating I'm going to State the obvious
rather than people like meat eaters
fighting vegans and vegans fighting
other vegans and right vegetarians
fighting vegans to just agree on that
one thing factory farming is terrible
yeah we should stop subsidizing it
that's the other thing I I wrote a book
it was an academic book about 12 years
ago about largely about subsidies and
and Agriculture and a family of four if
they went to McDonald's without
subsidies you know without Direct
Federal state local subsidies it would
cost them about ninety dollars
to feed themselves at McDonald's like
every part of meat and dairy is so
heavily subsidized every part of factory
farming is subsidized so that's what I'm
personally trying to work on is how do
you address that and stop spending our
tax dollars on an industry that's making
people sick and killing animals yeah and
then even worse than the the slaughter
and Factory it's just the life that
there's oh absolutely yeah the the the
the worst thing of all like in in my
view is the life of a dairy cow in a
factory farming environment because they
really have zero free range they
literally live like that tiger in the
circus just like and the pigs as well
pigs live in these gestation crates and
if you've seen them like they're not
allowed to stand up they're not allowed
to turn around and they spend their
entire lives just being made pregnant
and giving birth to more pigs um yeah
it's it's grim and I've gone to there's
this organization called animal save
where you go to slaughterhouses and you
just bear witness to animals as they're
being brought into the slaughterhouse
and it's so intense Joaquin went there
after he won the Golden Globe this one
he showed up wearing a tuxedo it was
really inspiring but I think it went
with Michelle yeah yeah yeah yeah she's
really good friends with him and Rooney
and Rooney's Sister Kate uh but what's
fascinating
and so profoundly depressing about
witnessing animals were about to be
killed is you realize that death is like
the only Mercy they're going to
experience like the only thing that's
going to like reduce their suffering is
dying sure and I sort of if I put myself
in that perspective like if I was a pig
on a factory farm the only thing you
have to look forward to is dying and
that is really profoundly depressing
sorry for bringing oh no actually turned
to like more light-hearted stuff like
it's fine it's important to talk about
it and I think that um again shaming
people is not the answer I think um it's
it's just a really tricky thing somebody
said very very validly that if
all slaughterhouses had Glass Walls Paul
McCartney said that yeah yeah that uh
nobody would eat meat you know
um I have a favor to ask you guys yeah
is it possible that I could take two
minutes and go pee really quickly yeah
of course you can cut it right here
we'll come back okay
I don't want to interrupt but at the
same time I'm like a little distracted
by how badly I have to pee right if you
wanted to get a toilet right here too
whatever you want oh is it still
recording or yeah okay so one thing
unrelated to sobriety veganism
uh murders in Connecticut
is so I'm sitting here looking and I
know that podcasts are not necessarily a
visual medium but you guys do have
cameras yeah
you have a lot of tattoos yeah to State
the obvious I find great comfort in
stating the obvious but one that I love
is the Alfred E Newman Misfits tattoo
yeah that is re that's really special
well thank you um you know Doyle from
The Misfits he's a he's a super militant
vegan wow dude now let me tell you this
my first pet
was a hamster which because of
The Misfits I I named him Doyle wow my
hamster was named Doyle and at the the
time when I got Doyle I was in
skateboarders it's straight I even had
like x's on my hands at some point
listen to The Gorilla Biscuits YouTube
today all this straight edge stuff and
then um
that was 10th grade and 11th grade I
sampled a marijuana cigarette and uh
Jazz cigarette
and and I it's just so crazy how
immediate I put down the skateboard I
picked up the weed and you know my
grades nose dived like I just like so
you were like a walking after school
special yeah and and Doyle died of
thirst
in 10th Grade I had this uh like he was
like a 95 year old major of World War II
we called him the mage
and uh he was in a wheelchair and could
not uh get around to do stuff so we
would go at my buddy and I we would go
and um get him in his wheelchair and
take him to the post office everything
they needed to do and this guy really
relied on us you know it was like
another part of an extracurricular after
school program my buddy moved away I
kept Wheeling the Mage around by myself
and then I sampled that marijuana
cigarette and I stopped seeing the mage
and and he would leave these like
heartbreaking voicemails Steve Steve put
down the weeds
Steve where are you like uh
it was like heartbreaking and like and
and I was just like um you know just
delete and and so the Mage and Doyle
were like the first two real indicators
that that I was just can we get a moment
of silence for Doyle made me an absence
absolute terrible
like it made me just a terrible person
right away so kind of a perfect little
self-involved dovetail of two of the
things we've been talking about so I put
out my first movie a couple months ago
the punk rock vegan movie yeah and so
it's about the history of punk rock and
animal rights is that the core of it
yeah so HR but I interviewed everybody
you're talking about you know Walter and
Arthur from gorilla Gorilla Biscuits so
Rey and parcel from youth of today they
used to be in a band called violent
children and in the early 80s
my punk rock band Vatican Commandos used
to play with them in Connecticut you
know in Bridgeport at this place called
pogos so I made this documentary about
the history of punk rock and animal
rights the most intimidating interview
was Ian Makai from minor from Minor
Threat exactly because yeah I mean
that's like Ian Makai was The Godfather
and it reminded me he's also the first
rock star I ever met so in
1982 83 uh I went to go see Minor Threat
in New York City
and he was loading up equipment after
the show and I went over and introduced
myself and I had the X on the back of my
hand
and I introduced my myself to Ian McKay
and I said Mr Makai my name is Moby I'm
such a huge fan of you and your band and
he was like
okay and also I was a very conflicted
straight edge person because I was very
drunk when this happened so I was I
identified a straight edge but I drank
and did drugs because I didn't really
know what straight edge Oh I thought
straight edge was like oh I like punk
rock and I have an x on the back of my
hand
um I didn't know there was anything
beyond that this is 1981 1982 like
straighta's had just been invented so uh
yeah we didn't talk about punk rock man
I like we were we had a conversation
with Fred Armisen the other day talking
about the best punk rock albums of all
time and uh and I was I was thinking man
I Against I evaporated and then he said
that was on his list I would go with the
roar cassette
it's the it's the same it's I Against I
but the first version of I Against I
okay at least I think it is so basically
there was this cassette only label in
New York called Roar r-o-i-r and the Bad
Brains made the what an album on Roar
and sonically and I'm just being such a
nerd it's a little more interesting than
the final version that they released
okay
um but yeah best punk rock records do
you guys want to weigh in I mean I'm
also older so like my perspective like
is is probably more of an old guy
perspective 13 songs I think that one
pretty damn good
like Misfits they they might be in there
I would say dead Kennedy's fresh fruit
for rotting vegetables
um Bagel abortions fetus or fetus I
don't know that one fetus and fetus yeah
digital abortions I don't know if
they're all time I mean I would say
damage by Black Flag is pretty Flawless
uh
discharge they're one of my I don't know
if you ever like discharge they're
British hardcore band okay
kind of like that that when when
hardcore punk
started to sound like metal like there
were other bands like dri yeah crossover
dri yeah and now a lot of like
contemporary hardcore sound is like
almost indistinguishable from super fast
speed metal yeah but back then it was
discharged for like
the first punk rock band to really sort
of sound like almost more like a metal
band but they're great I listened to a
lot of crass in high school
they had like the cassette we got to
interview Steve ignorant because he's
the original punk rock vegan like he
sort of
started the whole thing
um before HR
yeah yeah so Steve ignorant was like the
first like like I mean well he okay he
and HR and then there's a band called
millions of Dead Cops
multi-death corporations
Christians yep
um so Dave Victor from MDC I say him
Steve ignorant and HR from Bad Brains
they're like the three original animal
rights punk rockers vegan punk rockers
and um John Joseph from the cro-mags
became vegan when he was a roadie for
Bad Brains yep yeah he's in you you I I
presumptuously think you might really
enjoy this documentary because really
you know what because it's everybody
that you're it's
everybody you're talking about is
interviewing I even said to your guy
when we got here I said I'm so woefully
unprepared for this I haven't seen the
the vegan I'm I feel like I genuinely
owe you an apology yeah I'm so dying to
see it I don't expect anyone to watch it
I just think because it's everybody that
you're name checking is in the movie now
where could people find the dog yeah
it's for free
um because I made a movie a couple years
ago
self-involvedly it's a documentary about
me nice and we went the conventional
route of like
selling it and it's on Hulu and it
disappeared because
it it went the more commercial route but
as you know like if if it's not on the
home page of Hulu or Netflix no one's
ever going to see it and so with this
movie I thought okay let's give it away
for free and that way if anyone in the
world can watch it doesn't by definition
doesn't cost anything and so it's on
YouTube it's on Vimeo and it's and it's
also the distribution approach is
completely anarchic where we're letting
people download it and do whatever they
want with it that's cool like a bunch of
hardcore bands in South America are
doing a tour and playing the movie in
between sets
and they rode to us and they're like is
that okay I was like yes of course it's
okay like we're giving the movie away
for free for people to do whatever they
want with it that's awesome that's
awesome and and your your new album I
haven't heard that tell us about the the
new album oh so
put it in a little bit of perspective in
the mid 80s I was living in an abandoned
Factory in Stamford Connecticut in a
cracked neighborhood and I was making
around two thousand dollars a year uh
and I didn't have running water I didn't
have a bathroom and I was working in a
record store
and I never thought I would have a
record deal I never thought I would make
music that anyone would pay attention to
and one of my jobs was putting away
classical records in the record store
and there's this labeled Deutsche
Grandma phone
which is the oldest classical music
label in the world
fast forward decades later I played a
show with the Los Angeles Philharmonic
and afterwards Deutsche gramophone
approached me to see if I wanted to make
an orchestral Greatest Hits record and I
was like this is so weird because like
my introduction to Deutsche Grandma
phone was when I was living in an
abandoned Factory in a crack
neighborhood wow so that's what the new
album is and then I did a first record
with them with so many different guest
vocalists everybody from Kris
Kristofferson and Mark Lanigan and Jim
James from My Morning Jacket and now we
did that was the first one was called
reprise and this one's called ReSound
and the same thing like big Orchestra
lots of drums as well but then tons of
different guest vocalists
crazy that's great um when you because
you have music in a lot of movies yeah
and there's a couple questions I wanted
to ask you about that
um you've done the beads you've done
heat you've done all the the Bourne
movies is there a favorite movie that
that you have your music in
I also had um music and this was not my
favorite I loved his show but I had I
had music in the Tom Green movie oh wow
okay which one the Freddy Got Fingered
yeah okay and that's that's I I really
like him I appreciate his show I love to
show so much that movie is definitely
not a a high water mark in cinematic
history
I feel bad even saying that but I was so
excited for that movie and like it it
yeah so in any case of all the movies
I've done music for
uh the beach is pretty iconic Beach and
also I did like for a James Bond movie
yeah wow that's cool so many different
and worked with everybody you know from
David Lynch to Oliver Stone to Michael
Mann to Danny Boyle sure but the one
that is the best one hands down that I'm
most proud of that no one has seen is
Southland Tales by Richard Kelly
so Richard Kelly wrote and directed
Donnie Darko yeah
um and then after Donnie Darko was a big
success they let him make this movie
called Southland Tales
and
it got booed at Cam and everyone walked
out
and my favorite review I think was in
New York Magazine the journey because it
got just panned across the board
everyone hated it but the journalists in
New York Magazine said I don't even know
if this is a good or a bad movie but
it's so batshit crazy I can't review it
wow and but it's also got the weirdest
cast The Rock is in it wow um Justin
Timberlake Amy Poehler
um
Wally Sean who was uh in Princess Bride
you know the the little in inconceivable
yeah yeah so it's it's such a strange
movie no one has seen it maybe five
people have seen it did you make the
music for the uh movie or did you
already have the music in you because
licensing was a big thing for you yeah I
had a lot of the music was sort of
written and I gave it to Richard and
then he just sort of developed it as
score and it's also very well the
original cut was almost four hours long
and it's about
a a very baffling Apocalypse in Los
Angeles it's kind it's kind of like Repo
Man like it's it's Repo Man but longer
and no punk rock
and you are the music for the entire
yeah wow it's it's really if you're
there if you've got some time to kill
watch it because it's such a strange
movie and I just in this world where so
much culture is so predictable and
uninspiring this is not that this is
such a weird fat it's worth watching
just because it's so unique where can
people see that I have no idea
Tony Hawk has a skateboard company
called birdhouse which in 1998 released
a skateboard film called the end which
prominently featured new music and
fantastic fashion and I wonder if um
if uh if you knew about that
I sort of did so skateboarding is
something that has always scared me and
when I say scared what I mean is
so I started skating in seventh grade
and I had this little like plastic board
with like these little ball bearing
wheels and
in the spirit of full disclosure and
honesty I was just not good at it yeah
like I would go down a hill and fall
down every time and
then when I started DJing I used a
skateboard to push my records around
and so I got to the point where I could
go from like point A to point B on a
skateboard and almost fall down part of
the time as opposed to all the time so
so I have always sort of resented
good skateboarders because I I tried
like I really wanted to be like a cool
skateboard kid I just I sucked at it so
I appreciate skate culture especially
the intersection like skate culture and
hardcore culture
um but I've always been a little
resentful maybe I need to do a fourth
step around skate culture because I'm so
intimidated by like these cool guys and
they had like cool sneakers and cool
shorts and the girls liked them so at
age 57 it's time for me to finally
finally address my resentment towards
skateboard culture it was really quite
interesting about that it was shot on
16 millimeter film except Tony Hawk's
part was shot on 35 millimeter film it
was like just a first skateboard video
and being on it was just a staggering
budget that they shot it with and um I
don't know that it ever made its money
back plus they in in one scene
they uh they used music from Queen
and got the cease and desist from Queen
and then had to
like re-release it with different music
and uh so that's when they added mine
they're like oh we can't get the good
music
I wonder if they went back and took away
everything if if uh it'd be so sad if
your music wasn't in there you'd like
I'm dying to show you the like Steve
Barris part
but I'm just gonna be intimidated
because I'm gonna it's gonna make me I'm
gonna be like oh wow look at these great
handsome athletic people like wow I'm
just gonna go inside and like jerk off
and watch TV
I was in eighth grade ninth grade uh one
of my closest friends and skateboard
buddies is a mutual friend of ours
Charles Gooden oh wow yeah I actually
just saw Charles last weekend yeah I
love him I didn't know you and Charles
were friends yep we uh we recreated a
photo that we took in 1989 like
I don't know how many decades later but
we I love doing that like recreating old
photos
um you know he's and I don't know if I'm
allowed to say this but he's also in our
our cult
he's also a friend of bills yeah he
lives in Los Feliz yeah I see him over
at the lassens yep yeah your Junior High
buddy yeah he's the best yeah he's the
best and and man like uh I'm gonna watch
this it's the punk rock vegan movie yeah
the the name the original title
which
kind of wish I went with but um the
original title was [__] you were vegan
but then I realized you know yeah that
could
yeah so yeah and then I just thought
like you know in the spirit of Snakes on
a Plane let me just call it the punk
rock vegan movie
because it's about punk rock and
veganism like it's there's no guesswork
as to what the movie's about right and
it's also it's a ridic it's it's a on
one hand a very Earnest look at the
history of punk rock and animal rights
it's also completely ridiculous like
there's a period where um I explain the
history of punk rock to a dog
um also I'm dressed up as the devil not
just but like with full red makeup so
like sort of inspired by The Cinematic
history of movies like head
or you know so there's there's a lot of
absurdity and Ridiculousness it's not
just yeah serious angry judgmental
animal rights stuff I I love it I love
it I can't wait to watch I'm definitely
gonna watch it do you remember the the
gorilla biscuit song cats and dogs
absolutely okay from from their uh
was it future direction or they're
they're that EP I put that Gorilla
Biscuits EP with big mouth hold your
ground at even though it's an EP I put
that on my top five
deservedly so the follow-up album
uh One Direction or whatever or whatever
it was called it was really funny in
that
every single song was then mad at
something like without like without any
exceptions there was a song where they
were mad at procrastination there's a
song they're mad at watching TV we've
become become obsessed with TV they're
mad at there's a song they're mad at
racism there's a song There's they're
mad at yet eating animals cats and dogs
so for for the movie um Jonathan who you
met who I worked with he and his brother
he was a twin brother their background
is classical music and choral music his
brother is a choral director for a
symphony in Texas so they I had them do
a choir version of cats and dogs and so
we brought the choir to an animal
sanctuary sanctuary and filmed this
Choir in robes singing cats and dogs
while a bunch like rescued pigs walk
around it's a gene song I mean the
premise of this song is you know uh what
under the table he'll eat your dinner
like the veggies you can't stand what
kind of meal would he make we don't want
to ask it tradition is all that keeps
them alive but like why do cats and dogs
why are they so lucky you know like uh
why like why do we have this profound
reverence for cats and dogs but every
other animal
like gets
absolutely no that was that was that's
what turned me vegetarian and vegan such
a long time ago as I said like that
experience of realizing like oh
a cow has two eyes and a central nervous
system and a desire to be happy yeah my
cat Tucker had two eyes in the central
nervous system
and a desire to stay alive and be happy
my highest goal in life is to start an
animal sanctuary with my fiance we're
actually waiting to get married on the
property which we're gonna buy for this
animal sanctuary this is where we want
to retire this is our our whole thing
and um then my my my inspiration for
that other than just wanting to be
around animals and loving them is to
uh
to Foster an environment where people
can have an exchange looking into the
eyes of a cow or just like it's it's
funny you mention that because I lived
in New York for a long time and as
mentioned as I keep mentioning because
I'm a loud Mouse I've been a vegan for
36 years but most of that time was not
spent with animals you know except for
the occasional pigeon the occasional
cockroach the occasional rescued dog but
when I moved to LA I went up to Gentle
Barn actually no sorry it was Farm
Sanctuary they're right next to each
other and I went out to Farm Sanctuary
and I met a rescued cow named Bruno
and I had this moment
and it's gonna sound either really
simple or profound for me it was very
profound I looked Bruno in the eyes and
Bruno looked back at me
and we had a connection and all of a
sudden I realized oh
this is not academic like every animal
is an individual you know with
personality within that
and it's a very self-evident fact but
when I was like living in New York
getting all my information from like
nothing against New York but like I was
getting information like books the
internet films Etc there wasn't the real
connection with an animal and that one
moment of like
you could almost say like a soul
connection with this rescued cow
it just took my animal rights activism
and made it that much deeper right and I
I feel so strongly about the idea of of
starting this animal sanctuary because
again I've been so frustrated by the
infighting I've been so like um like the
the militants I think just the the
documentaries about veganism that lie to
people about the science of
you know that drives me nuts people
fighting about you're not doing enough
drives me nuts the idea of shaming
anybody for anything it's just
counterproductive to me and
I just want to share my own experience
and I'd love for people to have their
own experience to arrive at their own
conclusions with no shame with no shame
just provide people opportunities to
interact with animals and have that that
realization that that thought that you
just described maybe you could do like
you could take a circus and flip it on
his head where like the animals are the
trainers and like they train people to
do tricks yeah yeah when did Wendy's got
me pretty well trained I mean she's such
a little
gentle puppy let's talk about animals
I'm going to rescue a lot lizard after
this
that just reminds me of being on tour
boy oh boy yeah the first time I went on
tour I had this speak it dovetail to a
bunch of things we've talked about this
huge truck driver who was driving our
tour bus named Gene and he was so
diabetic
and he only ate at Denny's and he
wouldn't exercise and unfortunately he
didn't live very long but he uh yeah
that he liked a lot lizards a lot
lizards were I think they're a vice of
many a tour bus drivers and I just
thought because I had never been in a
truck stop before I'd never been on a
tour bus before I'd never I don't think
I've ever been in Texas before like you
pull into those huge truck stops and
you're like oh my God it's a world unto
itself they have barber shops inside of
them there's a whole deal yeah yeah and
and yeah those the the stores at truck
stops I assume everybody in the world
has experiences but like you go in you
can buy like everything from like and
Bucky's they're like wigs and CDs and
eight tracks and pep pills and
all right there those are
remarkable little apocalyptic places
they have great flannels there yeah I've
definitely on tour I've worn you know
like you're it's in the middle of
February you're like I'm freezing cold
let me stock up on six dollar flannels
there's a truck stop yeah we we all
spend a lot of time on tour
um well dude I gotta say man it said
this has been so enjoyable and uh it it
struck me as listening to uh
I don't even sure which one but a sides
and B sides like just the whole thing
and I was laying in the bathtub and I
was like thinking about all all my times
being conflicted or or you know just
thinking I was like man I really want to
just talk about
talk about animals and and and and and
I just didn't even imagine that we would
talk about so many things and that it
would be so enjoyable well thank you
guys for coming yeah parking in my
driveway and hanging out okay so before
we go I have a couple of questions
for you guys in so far as you can answer
it the first one's gonna be an easy
answer second one maybe less so first
one is who are some of the best guests
that you've had
I always like Mike Tyson
Mike Tyson was fun Mike Tyson was fun
didn't you try to like you ran into his
face yeah
um I think that the best conversation
has been my top two favorite were
Duncan Trussell and Kevin Smith
and I say that because those were the
ones that I felt were the most
meaningful
discussions of spirituality and uh just
what's going on in the universe Kevin
Smith I know I know Kevin's a vegan now
too oh yeah because he had to he was his
daughter Harley Quinn militant animal
rights activist and uh she got him to go
vegan he lost like 100 and some odd
pounds and he had to he yeah his story
about the heart attack was was pretty
intense
um you know the the idea that uh
that the brain is not
uh the generator of Consciousness but
rather a receiver of consciousness
is uh is something that we're pretty
fascinated with and and um
Scott here is a die-hard fan of of um
accounts of near-death experiences on on
YouTube and stuff and there seems to be
a lot of evidence of consciousness
being transmitted to the brain rather
than just generated by the brain and um
those discussions with Kevin Smith and
Duncan Trussell
stand above every everything else I mean
it's sort of it stands to reason
in a universe that's 15 billion years
old like every single part of us every
single part of everything is 15 billion
years old so like I've been a human for
57 years the matter I'm comprised of has
been a pigeon it's been a star it's been
an asteroid it's been over 15 billion
years all these different things so like
how could you
build a brain out of matter that's 15
billion years old and not and have it be
disconnected from that 15 billion year
old history so it makes
I think logically it actually makes a
decent amount of sense do you believe in
past lives
I don't know there's I mean I believe in
the complexity of things and I just I
just don't know so like almost every
spiritual belief I have is like I look
at the universe and I'm like wow the
universe is so complicated and so
fascinating
but I don't have any specific beliefs
except maybe like when possible try not
to harm things yeah yeah so fantastic
okay so so Kevin Smith
um and Mike Tyson I've only been on the
show for like 15 episodes now so but
Benny Blanco was kind of dope music
producer yeah he's a music producer yeah
he was a lot of fun
um and so now here's the part that you
guys might not want to use who's been
terrible
well I think the guy that we talked
about in the last episode where we
couldn't air his podcast people are
dying to know who it was oh yeah yeah
they were like I wonder who who was you
know we had one guy who was just like
tragically loaded and
um it would have been it would have been
a bad look for us to do that to him it
would have been a disservice to that
person first to to put that episode out
and it also
um
didn't it was the 10 minutes in I was
like oh okay man that's great dude we're
good yeah he didn't even register he
thought he'd been going for an hour did
you have you talked to him since I
didn't even think that it had been going
you know what happened was he kept
fumbling this like remember on Zoom when
you had to do it from your phone you
couldn't like where's the mute button
and then you'd hit something into the
screen would black out
[Music]
yes he kept trying to he just got that
was the least drunker and drunker and
drunker I mean it was a 10 minute
operation was it Barack Obama
I don't know
better yeah we're not we're not inclined
to to name the individual
you have a podcast too now yeah my
friend Lindsay and I started one and
it's honest I I love it like tell you
what I I would love to just keep talking
to you for for hours more because I've
been enjoying it so much but maybe we
could do that on your podcast and we
could um
arrange to publish them at the same time
and have them Drive traffic to each
other awesome
I love it um the one last thing I was
going to say is by the way thank you
guys for having me on but also I could
imagine
people coming onto your podcast and
assuming like oh this is gonna be like
jackass this is gonna be like just like
insults and Ridiculousness and we're
gonna slap each other and throw eggs at
each other's faces and but the fact that
it's very Earnest it's very thoughtful
it's funny as well but I I'd imagine
some people might be surprised by that
well it has to do with the guests you
know too so yeah good guess goes a long
way I think that I've uh I've worked
very hard over the years to conceal
anything
thoughtfulness but this podcast has
largely revealed me to be
um a little bit more than than the guy
on jackass and then I'm proud of that I
mean I have to say I have not I think it
was the first Jackass movie I saw it on
tour and I laughed harder the only other
time I've laughed harder in a theater
was South Park bigger longer uncut right
so like
nice well thank you for that and then I
appreciate the kind words man so what
we'll figure out a time to do your
podcast we'll put them up together great
because I think you live around the
corner pretty close yeah yeah right on
man thank you Moby I have to sneeze I
don't wanna
hold it you can face me that's what
Steve always does
now are you with me is Moby epic I love
the guy and I'm gonna peel back the
curtain a little bit right here we
recorded that with Moby before I went to
the UK just got back from the UK and let
me tell you that my bucket list special
taping was the best night of my life I
mean I've been I've woken up every
morning since the taping and like I I
can't even believe it was real I just it
was so epic wow and now that I'm back
um
where I'm getting together with Moby
again to record an episode of his
podcast and I believe I don't know if
you can turn it around in 24 hours to
get him up at the same time but there
might be a
there might be a double Banger I might
even be able to say hey click here
I don't know but uh but I love Moby and
I love you so thank you as always for
sticking around to the end and you know
what give Moby some love tell them tell
them you love me it feels like he's
hated come on tell me you love him
because I do all right thanks guys
thank you